DO WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW?
EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE
LAWS?
KOREA CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC?
HERE WITH REACTED, THE THE
AUTHOR OF "TRUMPED UP" ," HARVAD
LAW PROFESSOR ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT.
WELCOME BACK, BOTH OF YOU.
GREGG, I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
POURING THROUGH ALL OF THESE
MEMOS.
WHAT IS REMARKABLE, I THINK, IS
WHAT ED HENRY PICKED UP ON.
"I'M NOT SNEAKY AND I DON'T
LEAK."
OKAY.
APPARENTLY HE'S SNEAKY AND HE
LEAKS.
>> WE KNOW HE'S SNEAKY AND HE
SO THAT WAS A LIE THAT
STATEMENT.
TWO THINGS THAT JUMP OUT AT ME
IS THAT THE PRESIDENT EXPRESSES
THAT HE'S GOT THIS RUSSIA CLOUD
HANGING OVER HIM.
CAN YOU LOOK INTO IT?
CLEAR IT UP.
LIFT THE CLOUD, BECAUSE IF COMEY
HAD TOLD THE PRESIDENT, HE DID
NOT FIND ANY WRONGDOING ON HIS
PART.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS, PLEASE
LIFT THE CLOUD, COMEY SAYS WE
ARE RUNNING A TOWN.
THE OTHER THING THAT STRIKES ME,
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE
OF ANY OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THIS IS A RECOUNTED CONVERSATION
AS HIS TESTIMONY.
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE AND THEY
ARE, NO RED FLAGS, NO SMOKING
GUN THAT WOULD INCRIMINATE THE
PRESIDENT, AND SO AS TREY GOWDY,
WHO HAD SEE THAT SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO SAID, IT'S THE BEST EXHIBIT
A DEFENSE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO
PROFESSOR ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
YOU ARE ALWAYS WELCOME ON THE
SHOW.
WHETHER WE AGREE OR DISAGREE.
I HAVE DEEP RESPECT FOR YOU.
I KNOW WE DISAGREE ON A LOT OF
THE HILLARY PART OF THIS.
I WILL BE GLAD TO GET INTO THAT.
BUT LET'S FIRST GO TO THE LEAK.
THAT IS A CRIME, IF WE ARE GOING
TO BE TECHNICAL, 18 USC 793.
GREGG JARRETT, YOU'VE TAUGHT ME
A LOT IN THE LAST YEAR.
NUMBER ONE, WHEN YOU COUPLE
THIS, NOTHING ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION, ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
STATEMENT OF THE PRESIDENT, THAT
HE IS NOT A TARGET, IN EITHER
CASE, THE NEW YORK CASE OR
MUELLER'S CASE.
TO SOME TO NOT PUT EMPHASIS THAT
THERE IS NO COLLUSION WHATSOEVE?
>> COLLUSION IS NOT A CRIME.
I'VE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CAN BE
CHARGED AGAINST A SITTING
PRESIDENT FOR EXERCISING HIS
AUTHORITY.
ON ARTICLE TWO OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
BUT IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT, I
WOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK,
WHICH IS PROBABLY WHY HE BROUGHT
RUDY GIULIANI ONTO HIS TEAM, WHO
WAS THIS FORMER ATTORNEY IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF AN
ATTORNEY.
AS I HAVE TOLD PEOPLE FOR 53
YEARS, YOU CAN'T TRUST PEOPLE TO
NOT FLIP IF THE GOVERNMENT
CHARGES THEM WITH SERIOUS
CRIMES.
THE PRESSURE IS INTENSE.
AND THEN, THE PRESSURE IS NOT
ONLY TO SING, BUT TO COMPOSE,
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS A
WITNESS KNOWS THAT HE'LL GET A
BETTER DEAL IF HE CAN ELABORATE,
IF YOU CAN MAKE UP STORIES, IF
HE CAN TELL THE GOVERNMENT WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT WANTS TO HEAR.
THAT MAY NOT ALWAYS BE THE
TRUTH.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OUT OF THE
WOODS YET.
I THINK HE HAS TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK.
I DON'T THINK HE EVER HAD ANY
REAL VULNERABILITY FROM A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, INVESTIGATION
OF THE RUSSIA THING.
I WILL TELL YOU, ALL THE STUFF
THAT IS COMING OUT NOW CONFIRMS
WHAT I'VE SAID FROM DAY ONE.
THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
NONPARTISAN NATIONAL COMMISSION
OF EXPERTS LOOKING INTO THE
ENTIRE 2016 ELECTION, FAULTS ON
ALL SIDES, WHAT WAS THE EFFORT,
WHAT DID THEY DO, WHAT DID EACH
OF THE CANDIDATES TO COME BUT
WITHOUT RECRIMINATION, JUST TO
AVOID A REPETITION OF THIS IN MY
FUTURE, WHEN YOU START LOOKING
FOR CRIMES, YOU DON'T END UP
GETTING THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: DEVIN NUNES WARNED
EVERYBODY.
IT WAS PUBLIC.
AN OP-ED IN THE WASHINGTON TIMES
THAT RUSSIA WAS GOING TO DO
THIS.
IF YOU REMEMBER JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION, IT
WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYING, NO
SERIOUS PERSON WOULD EVER
BELIEVE THAT ANY FOREIGN ENTITY
COULD EVER HAVE ANY IMPACT ON
OUR ELECTION AND LECTURED
DONALD TRUMP TO STOP WHINING.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA TRIED TO HAVE
AN IMPACT ON THE ELECTION OF
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT --
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO SAID
THAT.
>> HE TRIED TO GET HIM ON
ELECTED.
THE UNITED STATES HAS TRIED TO
INFLUENCE FOREIGN ELECTIONS,
GOING BACK YEARS AND YEARS TO
CENTRAL AMERICA AND
SOUTH AMERICA, SO OF COURSE WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS TRYING TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS.
WHAT WE DID IS NOTHING COMPARED
TO WHAT THE RUSSIANS TRIED TO
DO.
WHETHER THEY SUCCEED OR HAD AN
IMPACT, I DON'T KNOW, BUT I DO
THINK THIS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM
THAT ALL AMERICANS SHOULD BE
CONCERNED WITH ON A NONPARTISAN
BASIS.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING OF THE
RUSSIANS HAVE ALWAYS DONE.
>> Sean: THIS IS A NONPARTISAN
COMMENT.
THAT IS WHY YOU CAN'T TAKE
CLASSIFIED, TOP-SECRET SPECIAL
ACCESS PROGRAMMING INFORMATION,
AND TO AVOID CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT, PUT IT ON A
MOM-AND-POP SHOP SERVER THAT
COMEY EVEN WROTE IN HIS ORIGINAL
EXONERATION OF HILLARY CLINTON,
THAT WE BELIEVE PROBABLY RUSSIA,
FOREIGN INTEL AGENCIES GOT A
HOLD OF.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
CRIMINAL REFERRAL TODAY OF
ANDREW McCABE AND THE FACT
THAT A COMEY COULD BE A WITNESS
AGAINST HIS OWN NUMBER TWO.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO COMEY THAT SAYS
THAT McCABE IS A LIAR,
McCABE SAYS THAT COMEY IS A
LIAR.
SOMEONE IS A LIAR AND MAYBE BOTH
OF THEM ARE LIARS.
>> >> OR NONE OF THEM.
>> ALTHOUGH, I MUST SAY, THAT
TODAY, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
SAID THAT THE LIES OF HER "NEW
"KNOWING UNINTENTIONALLY MADE"
AND THEY HAVE EVIDENCE OF THAT.
VERY POWERFUL LANGUAGE.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT McCABE
WOULD BE CHARGED, MAY BE AS MANY
AS FOUR DIFFERENT CHARGES FOR
FOUR DIFFERENT LIES.
AND COMEY MAY SOON BE SITTING
NEARBY IN ANOTHER COURT ROOM
FACING HIS OWN CHARGES.
I COUNT AT LEAST SIX POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL STATUTES THAT COMEY MAY
HAVE VIOLATED.
>> Sean: YOU AGREE WITH
CONGRESSMAN DeSANTIS' LETTER.
DID YOU AGREE WITH HIM ON THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE NAILED THE LAW, AND EXACTLY
THE SAME FASHION THAT YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT FOR MONTHS AND
WE PUT ON THE SCREEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT STATUTES, DeSANTIS
ON THE OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
CITED THE SAME STATUTES.
>> Sean: ONE QUESTION TO
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ.
WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME.
THIS MAY BE AS AN AREA WHERE WE
DO DISAGREE.
I URGE YOU -- I KNOW THAT IF I
HAD SUBPOENAED MY SERVER AND MY
EMAILS AND I DELETED, AFTER
SUBPOENAED, 33,000, ACID WASH,
CLEAN THE HARD DRIVE WITH
BLEACH BIT, AND BUST UP DEVICES
WITH HAMMERS, THAT TO ME SHOWS
FULL INTENT THAT SHOULD FILL THE
FULL MANDATE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, I THINK YOU
THAT AS A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN,
THAT WHEN HILLARY CLINTON PAYS
FOR A DOSSIER, THROUGH LITERALLY
A FOREIGN AGENT THAT THEY HIRED
THROUGH PERKINS COIE AND
FUNNELED THE MONEY USING
FUSION GPS, THEY HAD NO ONE
CORROBORATE THE INFORMATION,
PRESENTED TO A FISA COURT, THEY
DON'T ALL THE FISA COURT JUDGE
THAT AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE GAVE IT TO THEM, THAT
IS -- WE LOSE OUR COUNTRY IN MY
VIEW, PROFESSOR, IF THAT HAPPENS
AGAIN.
IS THAT DANGEROUS.
>> I THINK FAILING TO GIVE THE
FISA AND FROM COURT ALL THE
NEGATIVE INFORMATION SO COULD EA
NEGATIVE INFORMATION SO COULD EU
NEGATIVE INFORMATION SO COULD ET
NEGATIVE INFORMATION SO COULD EE
THE CREDIBILITY AND LACK OF